with pete kim so happy and and i even
text her after i said kim that's like
the happiest i've seen you caitlyn
jenner is weighing in on her daughter's
romances devin seems to be very good and
travis
uh
i don't have quite as much in common
with him while speaking on the podcast
fool send she reacts to some of the
family's latest headlines things are
going well first up kim kardashian's
relationship with pete davidson what's
your opinion on skeet he was over the
other day him for the first shot like
skeet and kim i called i was in trouble
because i called him peter and kim
starts laughing it's not peter it's pete
i said well i don't know i'm just trying
to be
polite
you know and to be honest with you
uh he seemed like a very nice guy kim
seems so
happy
and that's my number one concern she
also takes a moment to praise kim's
estranged husband kanye west even after
their family drama unfolded across
social media i get along very well with
kanye
i really like kanye i'm still today when
i see him we're good friends
um
i just have to be a little careful
because
you know he said some things especially
towards the family that you know
obviously i'm on the family side you
know
and i wish him nothing but the best and
you know
and uh you know i'd love to see him
again the best thing you can do to take
care of the kids because in the long run
it's about the kids when it comes to
kendall jenner's bow nba star devin
booker the former olympian says their
connection comes easy devin booker i
have more in common with because of
athletics sure and he seems to be a very
nice guy and i haven't really had heavy
conversations with him everything i've
seen he seems like a really good guy
and can shoot some hoops as for travis
scott caitlin gives the most praise for
his mom and dad and travis
i don't have quite as much in common
with him but he seems to be good to
kylie you know uh but to be honest with
you i really liked his parents
travis's yeah i mean they're really nice
you know they're from houston and
and uh i get along great with them every
time we have like a family event
kaitlyn's remarks come on the heels of a
watershed moment for the famous family
can you believe this is day one
literally this is insane
[Applause]
i love us
this makes me so happy their new reality
series the kardashians premieres next
week while she was a staple on keeping
up with the kardashians you won't see
caitlyn on the hulu show just yet and
that's fine by her i was never asked
and that's fine would i want to be on
the show i'm mad at you yeah i mean i
had a wonderful time with my kids it
would be great but i'm upset it's their
show it's fine this also happens to echo
caitlyn's comments last month following
a profile about the family she took to
twitter and retweeted the story adding
this sweet message quote i was there
when this started from day one i watched
it grow and doing the show for almost 20
seasons was one of the highlights of my
life to be able to work with my family
for all those years it was incredible
happy that it continues for my family
[Music]
you